and finally new rule
let's stop talking politics to each
other
everyone these days says that the way to
bridge our frightful
partisan divide is to talk to the other
side so we can hear each other's point
of view
no that's exactly what you shouldn't do
it never works
no one ever flips to your side talk to
them
yes but not about politics
it's true you would have better luck
trying to talk tom cruise out of
scientology
just don't go there
when i was a kid politics and religion
was just not something the adults talked
about it was considered private
and kind of impolite and nosy to go
there
politics was like las vegas what
happened in the voting booth stayed in
the voting booth
we used to have no idea how much we
really hated each other and it worked
[Applause]
so when people ask how do we bridge the
partisan divide
i'll tell you how shut the [ __ ] up
really really we
we never used to fight over politics 24
7. if somebody said hot enough for you
today
the other guy didn't say yes yes it is
because of your party's environmental
policies
true though that may be
but saying it at every opportunity
doesn't help
people don't change their politics over
the years
hundreds of people have come up to me
and said i saw a religious and now i'm
an atheist
nobody ever comes up to me and says i
watch real time every week and now i'm a
liberal
they'll flip on god but not trump
that cult is serious
facebook facebook used to be an
innocuous place to humble brag and
show cat videos now it's a cauldron of
political hatred
it was a platform to gain friends
now it's more about rooting them out
what's with this if you don't agree with
what i just posted unfriend me
[ __ ] you gladly
we need to get back to what facebook
used to be about
letting us see who from high school was
fat gay or dead
so look thanksgiving
is in a few days and that means spending
time with family and in-laws some of
whom we may not agree with politically
just don't go there don't waste your
time
talking to people about trump if they
haven't figured it out yet
neither will anything you say over the
green bean casserole
my childhood thanksgivings were always
in princeton new jersey
because my father's sister married a
country club republican
and i was aware my parents didn't like
republican politics
but they liked uncle howe there was zero
talk at thanksgiving dinner about how
wrong they thought his politics were
the ride home that was a different story
it's true james carville
and mary matlin the epitome of political
opposites
got married on thanksgiving day and it's
lasted 25 years
their secret obviously hate sex
is a part of it but but also
they don't talk politics at home
mary once told an interviewer talking
about the impact of the minimum wage is
just not something that is high on our
list of fun things to do
exactly especially when there are so
many other things you
can't talk about there's a book
i've had on my shelf for years
it's called 14 000 things to be happy
about
i know it doesn't really sound like me
and and you're right it isn't but i use
it from time to time
in writing because it's just a list of
random things that can
serve the purpose of getting an idea
started if you're high it doesn't work
so good
but i thought of this book in relation
to our subject tonight if there are 14
000 things to talk about just in this
book
we don't need to talk politics all the
time we could talk about
i could read from a i will a random page
baking your own bread
silent movies fresh cut flowers morning
dew
mahogany the three-day weekend slumber
parties
wagon wheels fortune cookies mother
goose sunday naps see
talk about that [ __ ]
talk about how the parking lot at trader
joe's is too small
talk about how pennies are a pain in the
ass and they start playing the christmas
music too early
talk about how 69 is never as good as
you thought it would be
just don't talk politics
you